[Applaudissements]
le rituel se perpétue depuis des siècles
au tintement d'un trousseau de clés
[Musique]
joachim le gardien de notre dame ouvre
méthodiquement les douze portes de la
cathédrale
[Musique]
réglé comme ça rend tout chose quand
même entre le tout est changé pour la
cause de paix sécurité et donc non pas
encore j'ai commandé un maître en son
royaume
joachim est l'un des rares à pouvoir
profiter de la cathédrale silencieuse
le destin de cet indien catholique et
celui de sa femme ont basculé il ya onze
ans alors qu'il venait prier à notre
dame
[Applaudissements]
un jour je croise en prêtre
ils m'ont croix rappelle madame aller
commenté fitr a été comment tu viens ici
tous les jours le mastrou sort donc je
racontais brèche le travail mais après
il m'a dit qu'il ya travaillé ici est
scooté tiennent bien leur travail c'est
le miracle le traiteur est vraiment mais
rate le break avant l'arrivée de la
grande bousculade des touristes delfim
redonne de l'alluré à la cathédrale
[Applaudissements]
voyez comment sont elles sont pas
alignés donc il faut c'est vraiment plus
aucun temps mais certains visiteurs sont
assez peu respectueux et c'est
inimaginable ce que vous trouvez des
préservatifs
non je veux pas dire ça l'eau du
bénitier changer chaque semaine seul un
sacristain comme fabrice a le droit de
le faire
non ça reste de l'eau bénite l aider
donc c'est pas comme nettoyer non plus
les toilettes de la sacristie quoi pour
dire vrai le destin de l'eau bénite
s'achève à l'arrière de la sacristie
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi ne nage pas couteau dans
l'évier
balou a été bénie donc par tradition
tout ce qui est bénie va plutôt dans la
terre que dans les goûts à 8 heures du
matin
joachim ouvre les deux énormes portes de
l'entré notre-dame rayonne sur paris
depuis près de neuf cents ans à partir
du 12ème siècle
des dizaine d'architectes se succèdent
pour la construire
128 mètres de long 96 mètres de haut
mille statues et 300 gargouille pour en
faire le plus bel hommage possible à
dieu le monument a même donné naissance
à des légendes comme celle de quasimodo
le célèbre personnage de victor hugo
surnommé le bossu de notre dame à
l'intérieur aussi les bâtisseurs ont
accompli des miracles avec les moyens de
l'époque ils ont édifié des voûtes à 33
mètres du sol
dessiner des rosaces parmi les plus
grands d'europe et construit cet orgue
gigantesque aux 8000 tuyaux classée au
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité
c'est le monument gratuit le plus visité
de france avec 14 millions de touristes
par an pour gérer ce flot incessant
une cinquantaine de salariés dirigée par
un patron en robe monseigneur jacques 1
voyage au coeur de notre dame de paris
toute la journée la foule envahit le
parvis
les touristes du monde entier viennent
team organisé pour certains l'un des
plus beaux moments de leur vie
[Musique]
d'autres jouent les troubadours
mais pour visiter la cathédrale il faut
savoir prendre son mal en patience
cédric sa fille amy 9 ans et leurs amis
font la queue depuis près d'une heure ça
va on n'est pas trop loin on est bientôt
à ça va rentrer vite là c'est la
première fois que la petite fille
découvre notre dame
une fois à l'intérieur la magie opère
amy s'émerveillent devant les rosaces
les vitraux qui les habillent retrace
des scènes de la bible c'est bien les
vitraux ils l'ont fait au compas comme
toi tu fais là
en fait ça représente à peine les
vitraux un peu la ville d'avant coupe
écoutez en petits morceaux comme une bd
mais
sur des métros on va voir la maquette en
une demi heure
la famille explore tout l'édifice
c est rentré dans quelle porte celle là
ils ont mille sept cents 700 en image
est ce qu on commence à construire la
cathédrale ils ont jamais vu la fin
vois tu veux tu vises 700 ans
cédric est émis sont parmi les rares
français à visiter notre dame
95% des touristes sont des étrangers
autant de proies potentielles pour un
redoutable chasseur à l'affût
chaque jour que dieu fait le père
terriens ce poste toujours à cette même
place et dès qu'un visiteur s'y arrête
ils font sur lui bonjour bienvenue chez
nous laissez moi vous donner cette
brochure sur la sculpture
vous voyez ce lit de gauche à droite le
père terriens parle cinq langues dont le
japonais couramment des fiches comme
celle-là il en a pour le monde entier de
plus demandés s'ils osent dire parce que
c'est ça les plus angoissés tout chinois
chinois alors moi je ne porte pas chez
moi et c'est encore plus folklorique
c'est un évidement se trouvait
intéressant en anglais généralement jeu
espagnol
il a mis des années à traduire
l'histoire de cette sculpture et ces
efforts commencent à porter leurs fruits
je peux vous poser une question bien sûr
bien sûr les apôtres de jésus ils
étaient douze ou treize je te les
apôtres de jésus ils étaient 12 super
resto je te choléra ici vous avez pierre
la pose de jésus sitôt dit sitôt fait
trop loin il a été le premier pape
c'est avec lui que l'église a commencé
pourquoi stockage
bonne question
à cette occasion sur la sont pas comptés
mais s'intéressent beaucoup
il a remarqué que les touristes
connaissent de moins en moins bien la
vie de jésus-christ et ne savent pas
toujours ce qu'il photographie enfin une
photo en général la photo souvenir
devant
pour preuve d'ailleurs ça parce que
c'est par derrière van de ven maintenant
mais on profite pas des riches est ce
qu'ils sont sous les eaux ils passent
devant vous êtes espagnol bojan z ou
dans des as du mexique enchanté première
fois à paris
le père terriens ne se lasse jamais la
fiche explicative à quelques mètres de
la remontée niort jacquin s'offre une
pause café
dès les beaux jours que le patron de
notre dame installe son bureau en
terrasse ici tout le monde le connaît
bonjour ça va bien la fraîcheur
bientôt
sans la vraie vie là on n'est pas dans
une bulle dans les bureaux voilà donc on
voit les gens en plus javari de fumer ce
que tu agréable
votre petit péché
c'est bien en avoir vous savez le
moelleux mais le mien il est visible
et d'abord un homme
tous les prêtres sont d'abord des hommes
vous savez on oublie ça quelques fois le
débit
et vous laisser ça sur ma note merci
monsieur bernard laplace de monseigneur
jacques 1 est très convoité au sein de
l'église
tous les trois ans son poste de
directeur de notre dame est remis en jeu
c'est le cardinal de paris qui prend la
décision
alors au cas où il ne serait pas réélu
monseigneur jacques a fait graver cette
plaque de marbre
monseigneur bérard il a été de 67 à 83
donc il a été 16 ans
héros vous espérer rester
moi je sais pas pour l'instant ça fait
douze +3 galles 15 voilà frisera elle le
record de bejar une partie de l'histoire
une petite partie voyez encore de la
place voyez un derrière
en quelques secondes la caméra fait de
lui une vedette à côté de mon nom mon
monseigneur jacques 1 est avant tout un
chef d'entreprise
depuis la loi de séparation de l'église
et de l'état en 1905 le clergé ne reçoit
plus de subventions l'église doit se
financer tout seul
bonjour quand j'ai bien avant un petit
peu d'euros merci beaucoup pour faire
fonctionner la cathédrale le recteur a
mis en place une stratégie commerciale
digne d'un supermarché
il y en a pour toutes les bourses celui
là qui est énormément en fait on au
brésilien il coûte 30 euros
ça en fait c'est très souvent des
italiens c'était bien parce que je vois
la représentation de la vierge en fait
20 euros la statue en bois et 24 pour
les rosaces ça c'est très très prisé par
pour les américains toute l'amérique du
nord
il y a même des objets en cristal à 280
euros
mais le produit vedette reste un grand
classique et les chapelets au fait selon
ici vraiment nos meilleures ventes dans
mes plans sur les chapelets on en vend
comme un peu près 90 par an c'est
presque une marque
c'est presque une marque avec une vente
toutes les deux minutes
les affaires ont l'air de bien marcher
mais le patron est quand même un peu
inquiet voyez pas beaucoup de monde
quand même pour vous j'ai beaucoup de
monde mais pour nous c'est pas beaucoup
de monde
monseigneur jacques 1 poursuit son
inspection au rayon bougies celles ci
sont réservés aux offrandes
c'est pas un peu cher 5 euros la logique
c'est une offrande conseillers on met ce
qu'on veut on les espère général
en effet on essaye on essaye et si
d'aventuré il reste un peu de monnaie
aux visiteurs ils peuvent s'offrir une
médaille aux distributeurs automatiques
ou encore faire un don en glissant leur
pièce dans les troncs
toutes ces ventes finances une
machinerie que les touristes ne remarque
pas sous leurs pieds des grilles de
chauffage aussi discrète que gigantesque
et pour admirer les oeuvres d'art des
éclairages sophistiqués sans cela
l'intérieur de la cathédrale serait
glacial et obscures avec plus de 30
mètres de hauteur sous plafond
la note est astronomique c'est depuis le
presbytère que le patron tient des
comptes natale et comment ça va jose
asseoir dans les parapheurs des dizaines
de factures les boissons chocolatées
c'est pour la machine à café j'imagine
ce 124 euros à payer ces petites
factures il ya beaucoup de petites
factures vous savez dans une cathédrale
monseigneur jacquin encore le sourire
plus pour longtemps ils chauffage qui
est de la vapeur vous avez de la ville
est là pour dix sept niches sont en
hausse que vous n'y correspond à 1000
euros par jour auxquels il faut ajouter
plus de 6600 euros d'électricité pour
les deux premiers mois de l'année avec
une cinquantaine d'employés à payer
monseigneur jacques 1 arrive à peine à
l'équilibré sur une année cela
représente 5 millions d'euros et les
dépenses se reprenne 5 millions le
fonctionnement de notre dame est un
gouffre pour l'église mais heureusement
les murs et l'ensemble du bâtiment
appartiennent à l'état la cathédrale est
considéré comme un monument
ce sont donc des organismes publics qui
en finance l'entretien
[Musique]
philippe villeneuve et l'architecte en
chef des monuments historiques
il est responsable de la santé de la
vieille dame
une charge qui l'autorisent à se
promener derrière ses statuts au beau
milieu de la façade
je viens de voir des petites traces de
mortier de joueurs qui sont tombés au
sol
donc ça sera quelque chose à surveiller
philippe inspectent les lieux en
permanence sportif c'est un métier qui
me fait regretter de ne pas l'être
bon alors si vous avez 5 minutes jeu
derrière sa portière il ya quelque chose
je vais vous l'offrir parce que c'est
bon si vous êtes sujet au vertige bourse
est pas un cadeau mais mais c'est quand
même quelque chose d'extraordinaire donc
c'est un peu chaud mais franchement vous
allez voir au bout du couloir
c'est extraordinaire et là mais vous
êtes au pied de la rosace sud
c'est une des vu que finalement personne
ne voit sauf à moins d'avoir cette clé
qui est le passe en fait le fameux pass
rouge que en tant qu architecte en chef
je veux je peux disposer et il y en a
que quatre elle peut ouvrir absolument
toutes les portes de la cathédrale
ce qui fit la joie de ce métier en face
et ça c'est de donner cette merveille
voilà mais cette beauté à un prix la
seule restauration de la façade a coûté
11 millions d'euros et les caisses de
l'état sont vides
désormais c'est à coups de système d
à 45 mètres du sol que les équipes de
file villeneuve lutte contre les
outrages du temps
donc là on va vérifier la fissure de les
fissures existantes sur la rosacée
vérifier l'évolution sur une année
à presque 900 ans lapierre s'effrite
pauvres si ça tient aussi si l'adhérence
de la pierre ou du morte du ciment qui a
été menée à l'époque
tiens et collants bon c'est fragile il
faut qu'on soit sûr que quand on n'est
pas d'éléments qui puisse tomber sur la
tête de quelqu'un donc c'est vraiment
une visite très sérieusement
larosace tient bon mais la statue de
saint jean menace de se jeter dans le
vide
[Musique]
les ouvriers lyon bricoler une ceinture
de sécurité
on l'a mise en sécurité donc c'est une
sangle qui est complètement douce donc
il ya aucune dégradation de la sculpture
et qui la maintient le temps d'une
restauration à un peu plus au pendu au
dessus du vide les couvreurs colmate les
brèches comme ils peuvent
alex tu as des entrées des opa ouais
contrôle bien tu me dis quand tu veux je
te passe la résine
kele villeneuve poursuit son inspection
jusqu'au sommet de la cathédrale à
presque 100 mètres de hauteur il ne se
lasse jamais du spectacle qui lui est
offert alors ça c'est toujours un moment
extraordinaire magnifique
on a ce grand vaisseau qui est notre
dame qui regardent la scène c'est
toujours quelque chose de merveilleux
mais son oeil de spécialiste le ramène
toujours à une triste réalité en
contrebas la toiture de plans du 19e des
plus étanche
si vous regardez bien vous avez pas mal
de rustines à droite à gauche des petits
des grands des marrons des des en plomb
dégrise y en a partout partout partout
c'est préoccupant donc
il va falloir maintenant arrêter de
poser des rustines est vraiment commencé
à travailler sur le vraiment le fond du
problème
refaire la toiture prendra des années
[Musique]
de 8 heures à 19 heures le défilé des
promeneurs sur le parvis est
ininterrompue tous ces touristes suscite
la convoitise des pickpockets
les policiers du ive arrondissement
veille sur eux
[Musique]
ils servent de guides par là bas vous
traversez la scène est âpre et serrée
boli et ils sont aussi une attraction
pour les touristes
au physique 36 points formation
enseignement polyglotte en plusieurs
langues
on est polyvalent mais l'ambiance bonne
enfant ne dure jamais très longtemps à
l'aide des cinq caméras de surveillance
braqués sur le parvis
les patrouilleurs ont une mission
quotidienne
c'est vraiment la place qui parmi
empêcher la mendicité est interdite
depuis 2008 aux abords de la cathédrale
sur les écrans de contrôle
laetitia et amel repère une mendiante
alors revenu encore oui c'est ya dix
mois est ce que tu as à proximité
l'adorent on a là tu sais la mendiante
qui revenu balai dans la file d'attenté
tu peux pas la louper un les policiers
interviennent c'est toute seule ici
il demande au centre de vérifier si
cette femme est inscrite au fpr le
fichier des personnes recherchées pour
rependre souris
c'est inconnu au père tu reviens ici
dégage tu reviens plus ici dans dix
minutes
sur le parvis les mendiants
appartiennent souvent à la même
communauté
ces jours le kin ball étiez
les policiers ont appris quelques mots
drum a répété
[Applaudissements]
c'est interdit
plus avedikian je demande est simple
identité et qu'ils ont nés de quitter
les lieux rapidement l'appui d'entités
ses boules et ils ont ce m'excuser de la
kz1 et pour qui doute et répéter répéter
c'est à dire rapide et ça me va pas
en parlant avec eux enfin les sages
linguistique en fait
[Applaudissements]
les huit cloches de notre dame ne jouent
ensemble qu'une seule fois dans la
journée
cela fait 50 ans que denise les écoute
de son balcon
les midis là et me dit ça car yonne
c'est merveilleux 1
voilà c'est le coeur de la cité qui bat
la voilà une autre avec et alors vous
imaginez ce son qui est le même qu'au
xiiie siècle voilà ça c'est très
émouvant
[Applaudissements]
une fois dans la rue de nice se désole
plus rien n'est sacré
[Applaudissements]
elle ne reconnaît plus le quartier de sa
jeunesse comme la rue d'arcole
aujourd'hui envahie par les boutiques de
souvenirs au début de notre mariage mais
je n'ai faire les courses ici il y avait
deux boulangeries
on avait une qui est un peu plus lent
l'autre côté à l'angle il y avait une
charcuterie et une épicerie
aujourd'hui plus rien c'était si un
charcutier voila voila c'était ici voilà
bon il encore un peu charcuterie quand
même pas à ça ça perdure
bon ça va ça marche le commerce
bon bah bonne journée insu d'avoir un
peu de sa jv que voulez vous tout change
en bien en moins bien parfois
rue d'arcole de nice fait contre
mauvaise fortune bon coeur
mais quand elles seront sur le pont de
l'archevêché à 100 mètres de notre dame
sa colère éclate
selon elle les touristes l'ont défigurée
voilà le plus beau cadenas
alors les plus beaux cana comment
dirais-je l'amour avec un cadenas pour
moi c'est pas l'amour à gannat garder ça
regardez ça c'est monstrueux c'est pas
mignon
un sip les curistes sait pas toujours un
cadeau pour vous ça devrait être un
cadeau parce qu on est très fiers qu'ils
aiment notre ville qui faisait notre
quartier qu'ils admirent la plus belle
vue de paris c'est le chevet de notre
dame et voilà ce qu'on me laisse et
regarder tout et tagué ici voilà tout
voilà regarder sa demande et la pierre
voilà tout est tagué c'est une
catastrophe
il m'arrive des matins quand je passe
j'ai les larmes aux yeux
parce que je me dis qu'est ce que c'est
devenu mon quartier et voilà il
photographie ça mais une photographie
plus le cheval c'est fini c'est fini
on verra le temps
bientôt les flashs des touristes seront
attirés par d'autres objets brillants
mais bien plus précieux
ils sont apportés dans le plus grand
secret par une porte dérobée
[Musique]
on l'a posée lors laurent prades le
régisseur est un brin stressé
seulement voilà posé dessus les portes
refermées
les ouvriers peuvent enfin libéré le
trésor qui se cache dans ses caisses des
reliquaires comme celui de saint louis
fait de bronze et de pierres précieuses
hommage à un roi qui a financé la
construction de notre dame
[Musique]
alors c'est cette statue qui vient
devant lui en fait vous pouvez tenir par
ici mais pas levé parce que sinon ça va
vous restez dans et hors du coup pour le
caler au fond pratiquement ses
objections au projet ces objets qui sont
anciens pour le royal il ya plein de
petits détails qui dépasse donc on peut
très vite accroché cas sector donc c'est
vraiment des gens totalement spécialisée
dans la matière qui manipulent ce genre
d'objet du bronze doré et sculpté orné
d'émeraude de saphir et de diamants
[Musique]
d'incroyables cadeaux faits à l'église
par de riches anonymes au fil des
siècles ces dames pièces de paris qui
ont fait don de l'ensemble de ces
pierres grises
ce reliquaire aujourd'hui pour laisser
quelques millimètres et bien droites ou
vanille un parfait pour admirer ces
objets d'art unique
les touristes devront débourser 5 euros
des volets métalliques sont toujours mis
en action le soir quand on ferme le
trésor comme ceci
dans la cathédrale il se passe parfois
des scènes mystérieuses
jean-pierre en est le maître d'oeuvre il
est le seul parmi les 200 bénévoles à
bénéficier d'un espace réservé dans
l'édifice c'est d'un placard personnel
oui sous laissé pour je puisse retrouver
rapidement mais aimer à faire et que je
puisse au magazine et des fois quelques
éléments dont j'ai besoin
voilà son domaine et au fond des
entrailles de la cathédrale dans la
crypte c'est ici que jean-pierre et
suscite des croyants oublier une fois
par an l'ancien professeur d'histoire et
son équipe relancée à la demande des
paroisses la production d'huile sainte
les commandes ne cessent d'augmenter il
ya eu 328 commandes
donc je prends une petite marge de
sécurité parce que ça je sais dans les
jardins tiens on va en préparer 340 de
vente eu des centaines de chevaux la
remplir d'un élixir à la recette
immuable
[Musique]
voilà une bonne odeur c'est une huile
qui est une base comme toutes les autres
d'huile d'olive raffiné et puis là ici
c'est de l'essence de géraniums voilà
alors il ya 85 % d'huile d'olive et la
différence en essence de géraniums la
composition est basique mais une fois
bénis pour ceux qui croient lui l'aurait
une vertus miraculeuses soigner le mal
que ce soit une maladie où vous avez un
risque important par rapport à votre
pronostic vital
donc ce sont des maladies tout de même
très sérieux si vous avez un simple
rhume c'est pas la peine je joue à ce
niveau
[Applaudissements]
peut-être ville sera distribué
gratuitement aux paroisses de paris
notre dame renferme encore bien des
mystères une fois par mois il est
possible de remonter le temps jusqu'à
l'époque du christ dans une atmosphère
digne du nom de la rose
les chevaliers du saint sépulcre partent
en mission l'ordre millénaire va sortir
de son coffre fort la relique des
reliques
seules quatre personnes connaissent le
code secret
ce
ce treillis d'or renferme selon l'église
la couronne d'épinés porté par le christ
le jour de sa crucifixion
saint louis aurait ruiné la france pour
l'acquérir au xiiie siècle
si je vous disais 13500 il perd perd
dord savoie rien vous dire simplement ce
qui va probablement plus évoquer quelque
chose pour vous c'est que ça
correspondait en gros à la moitié du
budget de la nation de l'époque
alors vous imaginez bien que c'est
probablement une couronne
enfin une relique qui est la plus
recherché au monde
ce soir sous la protection de gardes du
corps
la relique est offerte à la dévotion des
fidèles
la cérémonie terminée la cathédrale
s'endort enfants
mais dans la nuit à quelques heures des
fêtes de pâques
un homme vient troubler la quiétude de
la vieille dame à son d'arrivée une
gigantesque machinerie se met en marche
olivier latry est organiste lui seul
peut maîtriser le plus grand orgue de
france son poste de pilotage a été
modernisé il ya cinq ans il joue sur
cinq claviers et a le choix entre 115
sonorités à chaque fois en fait qu'on
actionne un de ces registres
on va avoir une sonorité particulière
dans la flûte la voix humaine ressemble
à tout sauf à une vraie vie humaine
olivier porte une lourde responsabilité
demain aux commandes de son monstre aux
8000 clio i jouera pour la plus
importante fête chrétienne de l'année
sa répétition va durer toute la nuit
[Musique]
oh
c'est le jour de pâques
les agents de la voirie refont une
beauté au parvenu
dans la cathédrale les derniers
préparatifs se règlent à la clé à
molette et au courage
elle est à peu près 300 marches à une
dizaine devrait près du fief de
quasimodo la galerie des chimères se
cache la plus grosse cloche de notre
dame
le bourdon il pèse 13 tonnes et comme le
veut la tradition on doit donner un nom
emmanuel on va essayer de le balancer un
petit peur lavernée ce que ça donne ce
fort à l'europe
exceptionnellement il ressentira ce soir
les accordeurs le test une dernière fois
s'il bat on frappe trop bas là il ya un
vrai risque de casser la cloche ses
besoins vous y prendre à trois parce que
500 kg donc on est obligé d'être à deux
homos au moins pour le bouger pour
vérifier aussi là où ça bouge pas trop
la voix du bourg où l'on ne se fait
entendre que dans des circonstances bien
précises
le bourg dans emmanuelle il est là pour
pour signifier des occasions
exceptionnelles des fêtes religieuses
mais la mort d'un peuple à la mort d'un
président donc des donc quand il doit
sonner on n'a pas le droit à ce qu'ils
soient en panne
[Applaudissements]
comme les sonneurs de cloches du
moyen-âge julien joue les équilibristes
il faut surtout pas avoir le vertige
ce sera embêtant si non
les deux hommes sont à dix mètres du
plancher debout sur le bourdon
je t'ai claira en dessous aujourd'hui il
est actionné par un moteur mais jusqu'au
siècle dernier
il sonnait à la force des mollets on se
mettait chacun d'un côté et on appuyait
on prenait appui
ça a dû être bloquée depuis voilà chacun
notre côté aussi les minima quatre
personnes pour la sono
[Applaudissements]
dans la tour nord se cachent les huit
petites soeurs du bourdon elles sont
toutes neuves
il y a deux ans elles ont remplacé les
vieilles cloche désaccordé c'est paul
bergamo qui les a fondu
la cloche c'est d'abord un instrument de
musique donc on va vérifier que le
rythme de balancement et cohérent d'une
cloche à l'autre donc pour ça on va
chronométrés et on va vérifier que le
décalage de fréquences entre les cloches
et bout tu ne m'en sa cloche va se
protéger quand même parce que c'est puis
sask donc là on démarre avec jean marie
c'est un la diez on va ensuite lancé
maurice qui est un sol dièse me dois
joseph qui est un fallières
mal
le carillon retenti à 8 kilomètres à la
ronde
c'est l'un des rares moments où sous la
charpente on n'entend plus le mécanisme
de la plage depuis 150 ans ce tic tac
est aussi régulier qu'au premier jour
grâce à des générations d'horloger comme
cédric une fois par semaine sans
électricité ni électronique
il l'a remonte à la seule force des bras
mes collègues ce qu'ils ont écrit
mais quand il ya 20 mois donc ces deux
cent cinquante quatre tours de manivelle
pour en compte dans la douceur et avec
l'amour je vous cache pas qu'après
approche du boul la veille j'ai pas bien
dormir la fierté après j'ai appelé papa
maman pour leurs clichés que j'ai fait
j'avais remonté dans le notre dame c'est
un pur tu m'aimes trois au départ
[Musique]
et voilà là il ya une âme là il ya
quelque chose parfaitement réglée cloche
des horloges rythme de concerts le
week-end de pâques
c'est l'affluence des grands jours sur
le parvis
la boue à l'autre
la file d'attenté pour visiter le
monument est interminable
mais bon
vous êtes prêté attendre combien de
temps pour entrer
je suis prête à attendre une heure s'il
le faut vraiment oui depuis la fenêtre
du presbytère monseigneur jacques 1
profitent du spectacle
on voit les groupes du tour opérateur
qui reviennent des gens mais elle est
parvenue thani mais on est très content
de voir cette activité parce que ça
revient c'est bon pour vous celle du
monde reviendra pas c'est toujours bon
ça sent chez de l'eau bout
à l'intérieur de la cathédrale 4000
visiteurs se disputent les meilleurs
points de vue
le business reprendre
mais aujourd'hui le temps est compté
pour les touristes avant ces saloperies
avoir fait avancer avancer avancer
monsieur d'un avancé selon plaît joachim
fait évacuer la cathédrale le temps de
préparer la veillée pascale
ces fermes avancé
pour faire ce qu'ils disent au crb
monseigneur jacques 1 organise la grand
messe avec jean-pierre le fabricant
d'huile sainte
là je vais y arrive pour que je reste
mais ce soir il sera le maître de
cérémonie
nous sommes à peu près à la hauteur
la chair il ya deux claire qui remonte
par ici il ya deux clair il est plein de
marche de trucs dont il longe et ses
deux fils tout est réglée au cordeau et
monseigneur jacques 1 ne tolérera aucun
dérapage
vous êtes attentif parce que c'est vous
bailler aux corneilles et rennes pire
énervant que nour kastler la célébration
étant à 21h il convient d'être là au
plus tard à 20 heures plus tard après
20h on ferme les portes sans le
dévouement des 200 bénévoles de notre
dame la messe de pâques ne pourrait
avoir lieu
[Musique]
test 1 2
il reste une dernière opération très
délicate à réaliser
la chine que la chine le démontage de la
croix de soins 202,9 avec eux les
véhicules et où les trois etc il est
vrai que les autres c'est bon c'est bon
c'est parfait merci monsieur pour les
catholiques pas commémore la
résurrection du christ
elle est symbolisée par cette nouvelle
croix dorée
[Musique]
face à notre dame les services
techniques installe le feu de la
résurrection
tiens un joli morceau
100% végétale
le bûcher est prêt à s'enflammer comme
les fidèles à l'ouverture des grilles
ils jouent des coudes pour avoir la
meilleure place des déplacements tout le
monde ne vous inquiétez pas
dans la sacristie jean-pierre le maître
de cérémonie prépare son entrée en scène
vous trouvez présentable je suis propre
et prie le tas mais bon je suis propre
présentable c'est pas mais un incident
va mettre en péril la cérémonie willem
notre siège pascal dans le gard s'est
cassé dans les vallées venez venez la
sacristie tout de suite
stéphane les sacristains stéphane venait
il ya un gros problème
le cierge pascal de saint jacques saint
christophe dans le cas s'est brisé en
trois et il est inutilisable
l' affaire est grave il est à son nom
le reconnais il a rendu l'âme
on est tellement désolée en plus il
était beau fabrice le sacristain appelle
tous les vendeurs de bougies de paris
monseigneur jacques propose que tu
mettes le cierge dans un taxi et à
bonneuil et on perd un taxi la
cathédrale vous arranger ça la solution
surgi des sous-sol de la cathédrale
je les retrouverai la carte heureusement
j'avais gardé
le challenge me le rappeler la série
maudite paquet sauver monseigneur
jacques 1 retrouvent le sourire toujours
un un doux mélange on reste quand même
chef l'entreprise pendant une réponse de
la preuve un siège passé ce soir
monseigneur jacques un doigt l'iran
public un extrait de la bible fonction
je regarde le livre de la genèse de la
traduction a changé cette année dernière
révision à 30 minutes de la fête dieu
firmament et j'espère
mais la nouvelle version ne lui convient
pas vraiment c'est un soir une femme
attend un quatrième jour non mais c'est
surtout que avant c'était il y eut un
soir il lutta matin ce fut le quatrième
jour des cafés et lien sur internet
quatrième jour vas-y pour déclamer un
donc non non vous allez parks
à 21h jean pierre met en place c'est
clair
ils sont rassemblés autour de ce bûcher
symbole de la résurrection du christ
et
c'est joachim le gardien qui a le
privilège d'allumer le cierge pascal la
célébration est présidée par le cardinal
andré vingt-trois
l'archevêque de paris le christ est
aujourd'hui commencement est fin de
toute chose et donc trans on le sait bon
des grandes fêtes de nay
[Musique]
le vent se lève augmentant la puissance
du brasier
[Musique]
patiemment les fidèles se transmettent
la flamme à la lueur de milliers de
bougies notre dame semble replonger au
moyen-âge
où
[Musique]